[Musik]
beeindruckender Tag nachdem wir gestern
unsere Soldaten besucht haben ging es
heute zunächst zum Generalstabschef wo
Inhalte die Kooperation war auf den
verschiedensten Ebenen bei der
Ausbildung insbesondere der Taucher die
durchs ja Kommando durchgeführt wird
aber auch alles was mit Entsorgung von
Munition zu tun hat wir sind dann weiter
zum Verteidigungsminister und haben auch
dort noch einmal festgehalten dass wir
diese Kooperation insbesondere im um den
Bereich des gebirgskampfes noch ausbauen
werden das war der erste Besuch einer
Verteidigungsministerin bei einem Sinne
gewesen Verteidigungsminister den jemals
gegeben hat das sieht man wie wichtig
diese Ausbildung der Taucher ist das ist
eine eine Region die für uns von
entscheidender Bedeutung ist die aber
natürlich auch
verschiedenste gefahren dann am Ende des
Tages war für uns für Europa bedeutet
wenn es um Schmuggel geht und wenn man
gesehen hat mit welcher Professionalität
hier die Marine das das führt nicht
zuletzt durch die Ausbildung durch
unsere ja Kommando Soldaten dann kann
man nur sagen eine Kooperation die in
jedem Fall einige Jahre an Fortsetzung
noch braucht
[Musik]